Here the correct answer is negative 9. Great work if you found this answer. If
you were a little stumped, that's okay. Let's see how to solve it. We want to
cube both sides of the equation, since a 3 is our index. A 3rd power will undo
a cube root. So we'll have x plus 1 on the left, and negative 8 on the right.
We need to make sure we cube this number as well, since we cubed this side. So
negative 2 times negative 2 times negative 2 equals negative 8. Finally, we
subtract 1 from both sides, to get 1x equals negative 9. Before we finalize
this as our answer, we need to make sure we check it in the original equation.
So I'll take negative 9 and substitute it in for x. This cube root only covers
x plus 1. This means I only need to take the cube root of this expression, and
then add 5. So we'll have the cube root of negative 8, then we'll add 5 and see
if that equals 3. The cube root of negative 8 is negative 2, since negative 2
multiplied itself three times gives us negative 8. And finally, when we add
here, our solution checks. In general when we solve, we want to keep in mind to
isolate the radical first, then to raise both sides of the equation by the
index of the root. And finally, once we have an answer, you want to check it to
be sure we're correct.